so why does that song work just one
reason you've seen how normalizing the
input features the X's to mean 0 and
variance 1 how that can speed up
learning so rather than having some
features they range from 0 to 1 and some
from one to a thousand by normalizing
all the features input features X to
take on a similar range of values that
can speed up learning so one intuition
behind why passional works is this is
doing a similar thing but for the values
in your hidden unions and not just for
your input layer now this is just a
partial picture for what - norm is doing
there are a couple further intuitions
that will help you gain a deeper
understanding of what batch tom is doing
let's take a look at those in this video
a second reason why batch norm works is
it makes wait later or deeper than your
network say the way so layer 10 more
robust to changes to ways in earlier
layers of the neural network say in
their one to explain what I mean let's
look at this motivating example let's
say you're training a network maybe a
shallow Network like legit regression or
maybe a neural network maybe run maybe a
shallow Network languages Russian or
maybe a deeper network on our famous cat
detection sauce but let's say that
you've trained your datasets on all
images of black cats if you now try to
apply this network to data with colored
cats where the positive examples are not
just black cats like on the left but the
colored cats like on the right then your
Casas
might not do very well so in pictures if
your training set look like this where
you have positive examples here and
negative examples here but you were to
try to generalize it to data set where
we will posit examples are here and the
negative examples are here then you
might not expect a model trained on the
data on the left to do very well on the
data on the right even though you know
there might be the same function
it actually works well but you wouldn't
expect your learning algorithm to
discover that green decision boundaries
just looking at the data on the left so
this idea of your data distribution
changing goes by the somewhat fancy name
covariant shift and the idea is that if
you learn some XY mapping if the
distribution of X changes then you might
need to retrain your learning algorithm
and this is true even if the function
the ground true function mapping from X
to Y remains unchanged which it is in
this example because the ground root
function is is this picture of cattle
not and they need to retrain your
function becomes even more acute or
becomes even worse if the ground true
function shifts as well so how does this
problem of covariant apply to a neural
network consider a deep network like
this and let's look at the learning
process from the perspective of this
hidden layer the third hidden layer so
this network has to learn the parameters
W 3 and B 3 and from the perspective of
the third hidden layer it gets some set
of values from the earlier leaders and
then it has to do some stuff to
hopefully make the output Y hat close to
the ground true value Y so let me cover
up the nodes on the left for a second so
from the perspective of this third thin
layer it gets some values let's call
them a 2 1 a 2 2 a 2 3 and a 2 4 but
these values might as well be features
x1 x2 x3 x4 and the job of the 13 layer
is to take these values and find a way
to map them to my hat so you can imagine
doing gradient descent so that these
parameters W 3 P 3 as well as maybe W 4
B 4 and even w 5 B 5 maybe trying to
learn those parameters so the network
does a good job not being
from the values I drew in black on the
left to the output values why I had but
now let's uncover the left of the
network again the network is also
adapting parameters W 2 B 2 and W 1 B 1
and so as these parameters change these
values a 2 will also change so from the
perspective of the third hidden layer
these hidden unit values are changing
all the time and so is suffering from
the problem of covariant shift that we
talked about on the previous line so
what that Norm does is it reduces the
amount that the distribution of these
hidden unit values shifts around and if
it were to plot the distribution of
these hidden unit values maybe this is
technically renormalized as V so this is
actually V 2 1 and V 2 2 and we're going
to values into the full values so we can
visualize in 2d what - mom is saying is
that the values of V 2 1 and V 2 2 can
change and indeed they won't change when
the neural network updates the
parameters in the earlier layers but
what - column ensures is that no matter
how it changes the mean and variance of
Z 2 1 and V 2 2 will remain the same so
so even with the exact values of V 2 1
and V 2 to change their mean and
variance while these states say mean 0
and variance 1 or not necessarily mean 0
and variance 1 but whatever value is
governed by beta 2 and gamma 2 which is
in your networks choosers can force it
to be mean 0 and variance 1 or really
any other news experience but what this
does is it limits the amount to which
updating the parameters in the earlier
layers can affect the distribution of
values that the 3rd layer now sees
therefore that has to learn on and so
bashed on reduces the problem of the
input values changing it really causes
these values to become more stable so
that the later layers of the neural
network has more firm ground to stand on
and even though the input distribution
changes a bit it changes less and what
this does is even as the earlier layers
keep learning the amount that this
forces the later layers to adapt to the
earliest layers changes is reduced or if
you will it weakens the coupling between
what the earlier layers parameters have
to do and what the later layers
parameters have to do and so it allows
each layer of the network to learn by
itself you know a little bit more
independently of other layers and this
is the effect of speeding up learning in
the whole network so I hope this gives
some better intuition but the takeaway
is that - norm means that especially
from the perspective of one of the later
layers of the neural network the earlier
layers don't get to shift around as much
because they're constrained to have the
same mean and variance and so this makes
the job of learning the later layers
easier in terms of batch table has a
second effect as a slight regularization
impact so one known into the thing about
passional is that each mini batch will
say mini batch xt has the values VT has
the values VL scaled by the meaning
variance computed on just that one mini
batch now because the mean and variance
computed on just that mini batch as
opposed to computed on the entire
dataset that mean and variance has a
little bit of noise in it because this
computer just on your mini batch of say
64 or 128 or maybe 256 or larger
training examples
so because the mean and variance has
will be noisy because it's estimated
with just a relatively small sample data
the scaling process going from VL to z
to their L that process is broken noisy
as well because it's computed using a
slightly noisy mean
Darian's so similar to drop out and add
some noise to in there's
activations the way drop out as noises
it takes a hidden unit and it multiplies
it by zero with some probability and
multiplies it by one with some
probability and so dropout has
multiplicative noise because it's
multiplying by 0 1 whereas - norm has
multiple if noise because of scaling by
the standard deviation as well as
hazardous noise because it's subtracting
the mean we're here the estimates of the
mean and the standard deviation on noisy
and so similar to drop out bashed on
therefore has a slight regularization
effect because by adding noise to the
hidden unit is forcing the downstream
pending units not to rely too much on
any one hidden unit and so similar to
drop out this as noise of hidden layers
and therefore has a very slight
regularization effect because the noise
added is quite small this is not a huge
regularization effect and you might
choose to use national together with
dropouts and you might use bash norm
together with dropouts if you want the
more powerful regularization effective
dropout and maybe one other slightly
non-intuitive effect is that if you use
a bigger mini-batch size right so if you
use a mini batch size of say 512 instead
of 64 by using a larger new batch size
you're reducing this noise and therefore
also reducing this regularization effect
so that's one strange property of
dropout which is that by using a bigger
mini batch size you reduce the
regularization effect having said this I
wouldn't really use bash norm as a
regularizer
that's really not the intent of vaginal
but sometimes it has this extra intended
or unintended effect on your learning
algorithm but really don't turn to bash
norm as a regularization
use it as a way to normalize your hidden
units and additions in there for speed
of learning and I think the
regularization is an almost zero
unintended
side effect so I hope that gives you
better intuition about what batch norm
is doing before we wrap up the
discussion on batch alarm there's one
more detail I want to make sure you know
which is that batch norm handles data
one mini batch at a time it computes
mean and variances on mini batches so at
test time we're trying to make
predictions johnny valued in your
network you might not have a mini batch
of examples you might be processing one
single example at a time so at test time
you need to do something slightly
differently to make sure your
predictions make sense let in the next
and final video on vegetable let's talk
over the details of what you need to do
in order to taste you in your network
train using national to make predictions